[Music]
welcome back everybody it is day two of
trial in Laredo Texas for defendant
Ronald Burgos Aviles the former border
patrol officer faces the death penalty
in a double homicide that prosecutors
allege was over child support money
Virgo sevillas had a child with 28 year
old Griselda Hernandez at the time he
was living with another woman with whom
he also shared children in March of 2018
Hernandez reportedly served the
defendant child support documents at his
workplace a month later police say the
defendant asked Hernandez to see their
almost two-year-old son so they set up a
meeting in a remote area near a park
prosecutors believe that the defendant
stabbed Hernandez and the little boy to
death on that visit to avoid child
support responsibilities Burgos Aviles
is pleading not guilty to capital murder
charges the first witness for the
prosecution on Monday was the victim's
sister Angela Hernandez she told the
jury she expressed concern time and time
again over the victim meeting with the
defendant over their frequent conflicts
about child support Hernandez called one
of those meetings where the baby ended
up with a presumed spider bite but the
chief medical examiner who took the
stand after Hernandez determined it to
be an injection wound from a needle on
Tuesday a key testimony came from Adrian
Bradley Dennison from Laredo border
patrol he responded to the 911 call by
the defendant and described the
defendant's behavior
he was just walking up and down back and
forth uh both towards me and then turned
around away uh he went back and forth
maybe about three times
and then he proceeded back towards me as
the MTS were were working on the on the
female
uh passed them as he proceeded past me
um
he sort of scuffed his I'm sorry not
passed me towards me uh past the
female's body he scuffed his feet a few
times and then uh he made contact with
that that large rock that I mentioned
that was covered in blood he caused that
to to roll uh maybe a foot or two down
the road and that rock in relation to
where the body was it was within a
couple of feet of her of her feet did
agent budos inform you that he had found
or had in his possession the cell phones
of either the victims no sir not at all
did he ever at any time inform you that
he knew who the victim's identity was no
sir not at all did he did he at any time
make any statements as to what he
thought had happened there in your
presence yes or no no not not in my
presence never
never mentioned that he knew her at all
or recognized her or anything
let's start with that Philip how
impactful is testimony about how the
defendant reacted at the scene is it
fair for someone to judge his responses
when they don't know how he reacts to
other things
exactly you got to understand there is
no playbook for human reaction and human
emotion particularly when you have
people who have served in the military
peace officers border patrol folks
they're very stoic dollid folks and
sometimes they don't wear their heart
out on their sleeves and they tend to
suppress a lot of their feelings and
emotions not to mention to be fair to
him he may have been under suspicion
immediately once they heard of the
connection between both decedents and
him so he absolutely had the right to
clam up and to hold that against him I
think is unfair well Brian lying at the
crime scene it almost reminds me of Alec
Murdock lying about being at the kennels
I don't know if that's similar if you
think it's different you think it's
going to have the same kind of outcome
for the defendant here I I think it will
and this is why
for everyday interactions we would say
once a liar always a liar if you're
willing to lie about this one thing why
would you not lie about other big things
and Phil would like this one falseason
Uno false it's an Omnibus it's the legal
concept of if you are false in one thing
you are false in all and it applies to
everyone witness defendant and so if you
lie about a little thing I think it's
going to make it that much harder for
the jury to believe him on other things
because he was saying oh I'm not I don't
know this woman I just came across her
being dead and now you find out that you
had a relationship with her that there
was child support that there's all this
stuff the question becomes why are you
lying about that I mean General basic
probably easiest answer is because he
was hiding a murder he did not want law
enforcement to know his connection to
this woman to this decedent because he
wanted to hide his motive and the fact
that he murdered her now is that true or
not I don't know but a lie definitely
doesn't help to prove otherwise
it's interesting enough we've seen
defendants take the standard admit to
lying and the lying before in the past
it doesn't mean they are always
convicted it's kind of it's very fact
intensive it's just because they might
even admit that they're relying or
they're caught in a lie Jerry holds it
against them but not all the time when
we come back investigators accuse a
woman of trying to abduct a child by by
pretending to be a worker from CPS we're
looking at her upgraded charges by the
grand jury and what the boy's father had
to say about the chilling encounter
thank you
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody we're
wrapping up today's show with an update
for you on the Ohio woman accused of
posing as a social worker and
approaching a child a grand jury has
officially indicted Lisa nicrelli
charging her with attempted abduction
impersonating a peace officer and
burglary
Jamie Spradlin says her four-year-old
son was playing in the front yard of
their Cincinnati home when mccrelli
apparently approached him he went inside
and told his mom that a lady wanted to
speak with her and later said the
stranger told him that she wanted him to
come with her the Crowley told Spradlin
that she was a child protective services
worker and showed some type of badge
nicrelli ended up entering the Spradlin
home to inspect it and even spoke with
spradlin's other children stole the
family that she had reportedly gotten a
complaint but when the family contacted
police they found out that CPS had no
record of necrelli or of course any
complaint against the spradlins when
police arrested nicrelli she reported
they told him that she had been drinking
and wanted to teach the family a lesson
for leaving their four-year-old
unattended could face more than 12 years
in prison if convicted the family says
to krelly not only approached their
young son but also touched him while
they spoke Tim Spradlin says the
encounter made his son very
uncomfortable
and sickening it's it
why why was she rubbing our child why
was she touching him the way she was if
it was her proclaiming that it was she
thought a child was outside alone then
why did she look at our the other
neighbors around and the other child on
the porch next door that my son was
playing with and
and why why would she just stand here
and keep touching him instead of
knocking on a door say hey is this your
child he wasn't doing anything wrong it
was on his bike in front of his yard
Philip how is that the prosecution went
in with one set of charges and the grand
jury came back with higher charges
the general role of the grand jury is to
investigate whether or not a serious or
violent crime has been committed namely
a felony and they can distill from the
evidence presented at the Grand Jury
proceeding whether or not the crime can
be proven based on probable cause and if
so they return a true bill of indictment
it is of no moment whether or not uh the
charges were presented uh to the grand
jury by way of formal document as
opposed to just distilling the existence
of those Crimes by listening through the
evidence itself so they do have that
Authority among another cabal of states
in the United States to return bills of
indictment for uncharged offenses well
now it's kind of like a whole brand new
case so Brian you think the grand jury
got it right you think they got it right
with this new top count I think they did
and I think it's because of the
statements that we've heard from both of
these four-year-old as well as what
occurred inside the home when the
four-year-old tells the parents she
wanted me to go with her
why did he believe that there must have
been some form of words or some sort of
words ever communicated to him that by
her that made it seem like this isn't
just her wanting to come inside and look
around she wanted to go to a separate
location that's the attempted abduction
and then going in and talking to the
other children the question then becomes
did she want to take just one child
multiple children and so I think
especially the abduction charge which
you didn't see earlier on makes more
sense as Phil put it that the grand jury
is looking at the evidence digging in
and it might not have been a charger
presented but the facts lead them to it
looks like she was trying to do just
more than harm the child by touching
them or or speaking to them but one had
take him to a different location it
sounds like you guys are not convinced
the I was just trying to teach them a
lesson defense although I'm not sure how
long that will last Philip Brian great
to see you both thank you everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice and
foreign
[Music]